hey guys it's Jenna here so how many of
you think you're addicted to sugar are
you trying to break up with sugar well
you've come to the right place
as we'll be doing this 28-day sugar
detox together so before we get into the
detox and also meal plans be sure to
watch of these two videos 5 signs you're
addicted to sugar and also 7 effective
steps to break up with sugar these
videos will help you better understand
what is sugar and how you can start to
eliminate sugar from your diet so what
is a sugar free diet simply put a sugar
free diet is one the limits both added
and also hidden sugars in foods
typically found in pastries cakes sugary
treats soda drinks and more some
sugar-free diets may even take it a step
further and limit natural sugars which
are typically found in fruits hiked up
fruits and even some vegetables so
depending on your goals you may choose
to limit only added sugars or both added
and natural sugars so if you're confused
about natural or other sugars well watch
my videos links are in my description
box below so form a 28-day sugar detox
plan I'm making this process gradual for
all of you for the first two weeks we
want to limit added sugar to no more
than 6 teaspoons or 25 grams in a day
and I want you to start replacing
refined sugar with healthier
alternatives such as maple syrup honey
or stevia but do remember that maple
syrup and honey are still added sugars
therefore they still need to be within
the six teaspoons or 25 grams limits
start adding more fruits to satisfy your
sugar cravings fruits attacked with
nutrients and fiber if you're someone
who loves to add sugar and creamer into
your coffee or tea will reduce them
gradually if you love soda drinks start
to replace them with flavored carbonated
water that has no artificial sweeteners
slowly illuminate them all together your
goal is eventually just during water you
have to learn to read and understand
food labels because most of the foods
which you think are healthy may contain
a lot of added sugars this includes your
breakfast cereals granola energy bars
smoothies producers peanut butter and
even yogurt so treat the first two weeks
as low added sugar instead of no sugar
at all because I don't want you to
experience immediate withdrawal symptoms
such as headaches fatigue mood swings
and even low energy think that however
some of you might still experience these
symptoms especially if your diet has
been very high on sugar now for the next
two weeks we want to completely
eliminate all added sugars and only
consume foods with natural sugars but
still keeping it within a reasonable
amount at this point it is very
important that your diet consists mainly
of Whole Foods and no processed foods at
all so you're eating a diet rich in
protein healthy fats and also vegetables
guys the good news is that your taste
buds and palate can be retrained for you
to adopt and less sugary lifestyle and
eventually you will not crave for those
high sugar foods as before the 28-day
sugar detox diet will be available on my
website you'll find at the links in my
description box below so I've created
both a normal and also a vegan meal plan
this is just a guide for you to
kickstart towards a sugar free lifestyle
feel free to change some of the
ingredients in my meal plan to suit what
available in your country and remember
that it is very important for you to
watch these two videos 5 signs to know
that you're addicted to sugar and 7
effective steps to break up with sugar
again links are in my description box
below share this video and get your
friends to join you on this journey
check out the videos right here don't
forget to also subscribe to my youtube
channel and send on your notification
button so that you
get notified every time I share a new
video all the best